und jetzt schauen wir auf die fahne ist
okay hier ist das video von mord hier
ist das video von fatih ist frech oder
ist schon frech
vor einigen tagen wurde mich auf youtube
ein video vorgeschlagen was mich
ziemlich überrascht hat denn in diesem
video beschuldigt ein englischer
youtuber einen deutschen youtuber dass
dieser deutsche youtube bei einem
anderen englischen youtuber eins zu eins
videos cloud ja und wenn man kann also
bisschen länger verfolgt der weiß dass
ich mich gerne mal für solche fälle
interessiere wo videos geklaut werden
oder wahlweise auch videos in denen man
so tut als würde man nachts um drei
fiktive charaktere anrufen und ja dann
mach ich mal wieder über diesen
deutschen youtuber der wirklich eins zu
eins seine videos bei diesem englischen
lied über cloud und wir schauen als
aller erstes mal in das video rein auf
das ich gestoßen und somit wurde auch
schon die beiden namen geschockt von den
youtube dies geht der englisch youtuber
ist marx ist ein ultra krass großer
youtube ich glaube mittlerweile elf
millionen abonnenten sehr erfolgreich
macht content ich mir auf gar keinen
fall selbst anschauen würde sehr sehr
auf kinder fokussiert aber er ist sehr
erfolgreich und das hat ein deutscher
youtuber namens er sagt jetzt fahr
tiebreak auf deutsch wird man
wahrscheinlich sagen hat die breite der
hat den erfolg von morgen bemerkt und
hat sich inspirieren lassen
die ganze sache das party von marx
videos cloud sieht sich aber schon sehr
sehr lange und zwar solange das schon
etliche leute dazu videos gemacht haben
unter anderem auch offen und ehrlich
schauen wir da mal kurz rein dieses
video in dem vater hatte schon ex post
wird ist jetzt aus dem juli von hofmann
ehrlich aber jetzt
marx entdeckt und millionen leute in
england und in den usa wundern sich über
diesen deutschen box also kommen wir
richtig einander leute in diesem video
von offen ehrlich berichten sie davon
dass marx dieser englisch youtuber es
selbst sogar schon gemerkt hat dass
partie brachte der deutsche bei ihm
cloud und nicht nur das ist sogar so
weit gegangen dass er schon einen tweet
darüber gemacht hat und schauen uns ganz
kurz mal die familie an die in diesem
tweet zeigt es ist kein job heute falls
es mitbekommen habt es ist wirklich so
links sind die fans von fatih brate
rechts von marx gebt euch dass es ist so
packen dreist es ist so packen 30
wirklich unfassbar alter einfach nur
sein gesicht über das gesicht von marx
darübergelegt er hat das von mox
genommen und einfach sein gesicht
reingestopft in das amt von einer
anderen person pro und das nicht nur
einmal sondern ihr auch einfach mal die
mutter von marxheim desto eher setzt
übrigens lustige packt altersheimen des
ewz das kann ja auch mal erzählt ist
wirklich genau der richtige um bei fatih
blatt in den videos mitzumachen und zwar
ganz mein video das locker gemacht hat
24 stunden mit einem euro überleben okay
gebt euch dieses amt von lucas san lucas
video kam am 28 august 2008 zehnter ist
eine tür hat hat das heim des ju
ernsthaft das fairplay von luca genommen
eins zu eins ist es ist nicht mein enkel
youtube hat das von einem deutschen
youtuber genommen und einfach seinem
gesicht drauf gehabt
[Musik]
ich frage mich was gibt mit solchen
leuten arbeit hat ich würde mich
wirklich schämen so was zu machen
hier sehen wir jetzt sein elfter oktober
2018 einfach mal zwei monate danach
einfach es ist nicht mehr so dass es
ähnlich ist er hat wirklich das fairplay
von luca rausgezogen aus youtube und
hatte sein gesicht drauf gelegt und wie
starbucks becher in den einkaufswagen
aber ja schauen wir mal ein video von
fatih selbst rein
dieses video heißt 100 euro tag versus
10.000 euro tag schauen uns kurz mal das
standbild ammann parasit schon aus als
hätte katastrophale verstopfung leute
heute werden die schon viel geld
ausgeben
roskilde
du musst nicht schreien wir werden alle
im kopfhörer drin oder sitzen an unseren
handys die so 20 zentimeter von seinem
gesicht in frankreich so also man merkt
auf jeden fall direkt dass diese videos
so krass auf kinder zugeschnitten sind
straight kids videos straight die sind
so was von 54 kinder gemacht das kann
man eigentlich nicht größer machen als
so merkt man unter anderem daran sie
schreien wie geisteskranker wie am spieß
liga und b dass die so krass lange pause
nach hinsetzen machen achtet mal darauf
viel geld ausgeben jeder normale
youtuber würde die sätze so sagt sagt
hintereinander schneiden so ohne lange
pause bei dem es ist wirklich so also
haben sie es auch die die vierjährigen
in der letzten reihe kapiert ja also wir
geben viel geld aus
ok zehn sekunden pause zwischen setzen
erst alle kapiert alles klar nichts
ersatz
[Musik]
das war geiler fünf sekunden einfach so
kloos auf dem gesicht von dem jungen
wäre so vor der kamera hängt der ist
also dass das ist wirklich unangenehm
zuschauen für mich bist so richtig
selbst sollte er hat seinen satz beendet
und starrt mich einfach immer noch so
zwei sekunden lang an
nächster satz bitte was soll das also
schon mal leute wenn man in deutschland
ganz ganz junge kinder unterhalten will
muss man laut schreien und die augen so
ein bisschen so zusammen machen und b
wenn man dann mal einen satz geschrieben
hat erst mal eine pause machen damit es
auch ankommt kann ja aber kommen wir mal
zum absoluten kern des videos deuten
nämlich dem dass patti rate wirklich
eins zu eins videos von marx stadt und
wenn ich eins zu eins meine dann meine
ich also viele identischer kann es nicht
sein so haben wir ein video going back
to school for a day challenge von marx
vor zwei monaten hochgeladen genau
gesagt am 29 10 2009 10 wie ein video
von partie zurück zur schule für einen
tag challenge vor vier wochen
hochgeladen genau gesagt am dritten 12
2009 10 also im dezember portillo kam
oktober deutlich davor jetzt schauen wir
auf die fans okay hier ist es wie die
von marx hier ist das video von fatih
[Musik]
ist frech oder ist schon frech und das
beste an der ganzen sache ist was macht
partie er schreibt eben die beschreibung
in die beschreibung heute kein mensch
liest die beschreibung allerhöchstens
die ersten 13 die angezeigt werden am
computer
er schreibt ganz unten in die
beschreibung ein ganz unten
egal also ob es waren mehr leute am
nordpol als am unteren ende von der
youtube video beschreibung no job da
kommt keiner rein
ganz und gar ein video idee von morgen
naja ich glaube damit versucht er sich
ein bisschen zu schützen so nach dem
motto ja ich hab's ja ich habe es ja
gesagt so aber da sehen wir uns mal
ehrlich okay bis die leute wenn ich es
morgen losgehen und ich kopiere ein
video vom juli bei eins zu eins okay und
da nehme ich einen kleinen zettel und
schreibt er auf chinesisch drauf ich
habe dieses video was ihr gerade seht
von fury bei eins zu eins geklaut ok
diesen zettel stecke ich mir dann in die
haarspitzen okay das ist ungefähr so das
gleiche level von erkenntlich machen
nach außen hin zeigen kein mensch liest
die beschreibung okay nobody kanzler
direkt lassen das ist die erste sache
die zweite sache ist das video idee von
morgens einfach so krank untertrieben
ist der ja es ist nicht nur die video
idee es ist das thumbnail eins zu eins
wirklich aber nicht nur dass dann auch
der video aufbau selbst so fängt das
video von morgens an
heute gehen wir zurück zur schule wer in
den kommenden prüfungen am wenigsten
punkte bekommt muss eine heftige
bestrafung machen denke dass leute es
sind wirklich eins zu eins die gleichen
sätze er sagt sogar die gleichen sätze
wie marx und das geht die ganze zeit so
weiter als nächstes video von marx vor
einem monat war jubelte alba also was
auch immer du baust ich hoffe dass wir
hier von fatih vor zwei wochen deutlich
danach egal was du baust ich kaufe es
dir wieder selbe sache thumbnail ist
wirklich absolut gleich das einzige ist
dass marx im hintergrund ein ferrari
autohaus hat und ein ferrari davor und
fertig nicht ganz kreativ habe diesmal
und lamborghini genommen vielleicht muss
man dafür ein kompliment machte er hat
schon mal kein ferrari genommen sondern
lamborghini aber ansonsten die mutter
von morgens hat einen grünen pulli an
gewusst und volkswirt bei fatih wieder
ersetzt durch seinen des ju er hat auch
in grünes kleidungsstück an der mutter
von marx kommt dampf aus den lustigen
weise beisheim dass wir auch
wahrscheinlich video idee von morgen und
der geht genauso weiter leute vor vier
monaten von morgen seating only one
color of three four hours schaut sich
das genauer an bedingt dass ich wieder
ein
vor drei monaten nur die farbe hessen
die man trägt von fatih komplett
shameless einfach eins zu eins eins zu
eins zu eins das amt übernommen
die mutter von marx die grünen hat als
farbe wird von einem kleinen jungen
ersetzt bismark selbst so wahrscheinlich
hätte doch irgendwie so ein bisschen so
eine persönlichkeitsstörung mittlerweile
denkt er ist wirklich morges und marks
vater der gelb hat ist sein des ju
so krank es ist einfach so krank gleich
oder wie soll das echt so krass und was
auch heftig ist sondern mal in die
kommentare von fatih schauen will sieht
man das unter jedem video die kommentare
deaktiviert sind jedes video weiß bisher
gefunden haben hat keine kommentare
darunter denkt euch jetzt vielleicht das
macht derweil keine hey kommentare
glaube ich nicht ich glaube das liegt
daran dass youtube ihm die kommentare
gesperrt hat das ist ein phänomen das
gab es im vergangenen jahr mal unter
anderem julia boutiques glaube ich weil
die öfter wie es mit ihrer kleinen
schwester gemacht hat und dann gesagt
hat okay da sind kleine kinder in diesen
videos oder diese videos sind speziell
für keine kinder gemacht da dürfen wir
keine kommentare runtermachen aus
jugendschutzgründen aber ich habe schon
viel zu viel arbeit viel zu viele
aufgaben zu diesem video schreiben
kommentare rein was ihr von diesem
youtube erhaltet kannte ihn vorher schon
oder nicht und was denkt ihr euch
nachdem wir jetzt dieses video gesehen
habt ich meine schon erstmal raus wenn
ihr mehr dazu sehen wollt lasse mich
gerne wissen dann mache ich gern noch
ein video für euch ihr kriegt hier
einfach ich vorgeschlagen ist wieder zum
weiterschauen die oben könnte man kann
ja ich bin raus machte vor augen